tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates a
time of reckoning for America's police
forces acts the brutality caught on tape
compassion now along with calls for new
laws and reform some want cities to
defund the police we're joined by the
leader of the National Association of
black law enforcement officers and the
executive director of a progressive
Police Foundation Plus let's not forget
the pandemic what will the days of
protest mean to the spread of the virus
and what's the latest on a vaccine dr.
William Schaffner is here with the very
latest and the week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
editors of meaty ight who did well
violence and brutality
all's flag provocation from the lauren
crime Network this is Brian Ross
investigator thank you for joining us
and welcome to our viewers on YouTube
live and Facebook live i'm brian ross
joined today by my colleague at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and rhonda it was
15 days ago today that george Floyd was
killed in police custody in Minneapolis
today he was laid to rest in Houston
after an emotional church service that
eulogized him and of those two weeks
Floyd has seen an extraordinary
afterlife if you will as a symbol of
police brutality and racial injustice
his name now a rallying cry for change
his death reigniting the black lives
matter movement across the country
today's service not far from where
George Floyd grew up it will include
music Bible readings remembrances by
family members a video message from
former Vice President Joe Biden who
visited Joan
I can't turn away you must not turn away
we cannot leave this moment thinking we
can once again turn away from racism
that stings that our very soul we've
also seen the family come forward
alongside the family of Michael Brown
the family of Botham Jean the family of
ottoman Aubry all of them here standing
strong with George Floyd's family
a somber homecoming for George Floyd in
Houston where the hearse carrying his
casket arrived the Floyd family church
this morning for a public memorial
attended by thousands thank you we will
get justice we will get it we would not
let this door closed and around the
country today we are hearing the term
defund the police the Minneapolis City
Council decided that they would diss
Lant disband their police force so we
are fortunate to have with us today two
leading experts we have Charles Wilson
the chairman of the National Association
of black law enforcement officers and
along with Chuck Wexler who is the
chairman of the executive director of
the police executive Research Forum and
gentlemen let me start Chuck by asking
you what are we seeing around the
country in terms of calls for reform and
change in police departments well I
think you're hearing a lot of support
for a reform you know you can't watch
that video from Minneapolis and not feel
a sense of you know horror if you will
at what mr. Floyd went through that is
not what professional policing looks
like that is a failure and it's sad it's
sad on so many respects but number one
mr. Floyd but I think there's also
opportunity the country is engaged in
this issue policing is very important
and I think we have to take a hard look
we've come you know good distance but we
have a lot more to do how do we take
this incident and make it an opportunity
to really rethink how we do business
policing is important we can't walk away
from policing and that's the key how do
we take what we are feeling what people
are seeing is I've never seen anything
like it you have to go back to the 60s
to see what we're seeing today so
there's a moment let's not squander it
and Chuck when they talk to us like let
me ask you O Brien is back with us
Charles Wilson let me ask you as the
chairman of the National Black Law
Enforcement Officers Association what's
it like to be a black officer in the
middle of all this oh it's it's hard we
have to balance both being a long
Horseman officer and being a member of
that that community that is feeling
oppressed when people have to recognize
is that this is nothing new for people
in the black community
this this has gone on for ages did we
have often said to people as well as our
counterparts that the institution of
policing is inherently biased against
people of color and low-income and was
designed to be that way when you look
back on the the overall history of
policing at least in America this is
what black people were have been forced
to live with as long force with officers
we we try to balance the the the concept
of working within the community letting
people know that we're there to treat
them with dignity and respect because
that's the only way you can make strong
relationships and bonds with people in
the community and Chuck Wexler you've
led a group that has urged reforms in
Police Department's around the country
but oftentimes you've had a lot of
pushback from police unions now with the
demands for defunding the police is
there a better pathway to reforms and
how about the idea of defunding what
does that mean to you Oh Brian that's
that's a really good question uh you
know you had we had a terrible incident
in Minneapolis the world you know it's
interesting it we can say this the world
I've heard from people from Northern
Ireland I've heard from Jordan everybody
looks at the United States and they say
how could this happen
so at the very moment that the attention
of the world is is focused on us that's
not a time to step back from policing so
I think you know when people say
defunding that that means different
things different people if what you're
talking about
r10 the police work with social service
agencies and mental health agencies can
can the police work with agencies to get
kids jobs so they don't have to get in
crime they get involved in crime can we
do something about our education system
all of those things are great but at the
end of the day when you're in crisis and
you need help you want a humane police
officer responding so you know defunding
the police isn't problem-solving its
walking away let's double down this
isn't about money this is about
commitment so I you know this is an
outrage and I think people are saying
you know they're angry at the police I
just think that as we think as we think
about the few
let's think about how do we work
collaboratively I'll give you an example
of how I think we can work
collaboratively let's suppose a mother
has a child and he's out of control he's
not on his medication well who do they
call they call 911 now are the police
the best response to that I don't think
so
I think you want crisis intervention
specialist social workers people from
mental health community that's who
people want to respond the question is
when that happens at two o'clock in the
morning will those agencies be there or
could we do something like take one
police officer one mental health worker
they do this in places like New Haven
and Providence Rhode Island so I think
we should be creative in our
problem-solving yeah yes Charles like
Chuck I I have been on the phone with
people from from Germany in London we
have to find different ways to interact
with people we have to reimage our way
of doing things that idea of defunding
or disbanding the police not a good idea
I and and in fact I have to take that
that same issue to my board next week
because we we've had so many people
asking us for advice and opinions on it
[Music]
we have to reimage policing so that
people see us as guardians instead of
warriors in the community
we have to be more critical about the
who we hire how we hire what we train
how we train who supervises how their
supervisor what policies and procedures
are we putting in place to guide
everything else that we do but Chuck
Ressler you talk all the time with the
most important leading police chief's in
the country are they doing a good job of
hiring minorities people of color and
what happened to the notion of community
policing
well Brian that's a really good question
you know one of the things we've learned
for the last thirty years is we want our
police departments to be reflective of
their communities so there's a real push
to diversify the ranks so these younger
officers who are coming on they you want
them to be minorities you want them to
be women which is an interesting
question too because if they were to
defund a police department like like
they've talked about in Los Angeles or
New York ninety percent of a Police
Department's budget is personnel only
ten percent is technology training
technical assistance so if you cut a
Police Department's budget what you're
going to have to do is two things that
would probably happen since it's 90
percent of personnel you would you would
not be hiring new people and you'd have
to layoff the first hired which tends to
be the younger officers the diverse
officers it's a real challenge getting
your workforce to be diverse today what
we've seen since Ferguson recruitment
and hiring is really down more options
for minorities and women and think about
if you're a minority and you're seeing
what's happening with the police is this
the occupation you want so that's a real
challenge going forward how are we going
to get the best and the brightest to
come forward how are we going to make
sure we have a diverse workforce how are
we going to recruit and compete with the
private sector when we talk about the
funding the police
has to be measured against you know how
important it is to have a diverse
workforce Charles wasn't let me ask you
this what about what they call the blue
line cops don't want to give up other
cops criticize other cops isn't it time
that officers spoke out about the people
in their ranks that are doing a lot of
violence and damage to the reputation of
police forces I'm going to tell you
absolutely yes when you as a police
officer observe someone else who is
either acting inappropriately acting
illegally using excessive force or just
point play being disrespectful of the
people that we are sworn to serve and
you do nothing you say nothing you are
just as guilty as they are they are in
word more dangerous to us as law
enforcement officers than the people
that we go out there to try to arrest
here in Rhode Island I'm working with
with legislators to institute state code
that mandates the the idea of duty to
intervene now what nobody knew at the
time was that Minneapolis actually had
it in their use of force policy correct
but see the problem is if it's in policy
and you don't enforce your policy it
does you no good that's why we look
absolutely in charecter yeah that's why
we're looking here salute you're right
about it
and so finally Chuck doctor that's part
of the issue within the policy but it's
not being enforced what's the good of
the policy well you know I think Charles
raised a good point on duty to intervene
we had our guiding principles on use of
force in 2016
number one was the sanctity of human
life number two was the duty to
intervene number three was a duty to
render first aid you go back to the
Rodney King incident thirty years ago
and the big takeaway this two takeaways
obviously number one the brutality
against Rodney King but number two the
role that that sergeant stacy Keane had
that day in his responsibilities that
was 30 years ago and some departments
and that's where our best practice came
from is is that was one of the best
practices but in Minneapolis you have a
situation where the the officer involved
Shabbos 19-year veteran field training
officer he's he's the one that is on mr.
Floyd's neck the two officers who are
around him are both four day rookies so
you have a cultural issue where you want
those officers to intervene how do they
do that when the person who is causing
the damage you know is is acting wrong
in a way that's it's it's a disaster
that is both a cultural issue and a
policy issue we can change the policy
what's gonna make a difference is when
every police officer recognizes in these
situations I'm going to do the right
thing and I'm going to save that man's
life and I'm going to save that cops
career there's a win-win situation
that's that you know Rodney King
incident happened because poor
supervision and a culture issue and this
into 30 years later happened but if in
either of those situations if officers
had intervened to stop it would be
incredible huge point
absolutely what Chuck wicker yeah well I
want to thank both of you Chuck buckler
from the police executive Research
Foundation and Charles Wilson from the
National Association of black law
enforcement officers thank you both for
being here
fascinating insights appreciate very
much coming up the race for a vaccine
let's not forget there's a pandemic and
all those police videos of officers
acting so brutally what will happen to
them is there a way to prosecute them
when we come back you're watching the
law and crime trial Network well this
week it was a sign of the determination
and the passion of tens of thousands of
Americans who chose to go into the
streets to protest what's been happening
oftentimes
forgetting social distancing not wearing
masks let's not forget there is a
pandemic and we still don't know what
the impact will be of all those protests
on the streets involving so many
Americans and we also learned this week
how little we know about what's next
with this pandemic with major confusion
and disinformation still coming out I
talked earlier today with dr. William
Schaffner of the Vanderbilt University
Medical School dr. Shafter thank you so
much for joining us yesterday the w-h-o
said people who didn't have symptoms
only rarely could pass on the virus
today they're backing off that statement
what's the fact and what's going on with
the confusion at the w-h-o well the
w-h-o certainly did provide confusion
and I'm so glad they're backing off
Brian because we we know that people who
have no symptoms at all despite the fact
that they're infected with the virus and
people who have only minor symptoms but
don't consider themselves sick can be
out and about spread spreading this
viral infection in fact we think they
caused a substantial amount of the
contagiousness of this virus and so I'm
glad the w-h-o is walking
back and as you know dr. Shafter over
the last three or four months they first
said there was no human to human
transmission and then they actually
suggested mass current that helpful
now they're saying rare with the
asymptomatic backing that off is there a
problem with the w-h-o and getting their
story straight there may be some problem
with the w-h-o but there's a larger
issue of course as we have a new
infection on the human scene that's
spreading around the world we've never
seen this virus before we always tell
people the more we learn we will update
our recommendations and so there's been
that sort of process which frankly is
hard for some people to understand that
yes what I knew last week and told you
may have to be modified because since
then I've learned some more and so we've
seen in the US and some places reopening
in other states a new spike of
infectious diseases and around the world
especially in the Americas in the
southern part of the hemisphere the
thing is raging still oh there isn't any
doubt that kovat virus is still running
around the world and as you say in the
southern hemisphere where they're having
our they're having their winter while
we're having our summer they the virus
is spreading widely in in Brazil Chile
Peru and other countries so that may be
a harbinger of what's to come when we
start getting our winter again along
with influenza so we're likely to have a
double-barrel viral respiratory season
coming up this year and do you think dr.
Shafter it will be as devastating as
this first wave of the kovat 19
illnesses I think it could be quite as
serious because remember the virus hit
us toward the end of our influenza
season this next go-around it will have
a chance to have a run-in along with
influenza and if both viruses are out
there making people sick
that will put a special strain on the
healthcare system all the more reason
make a resolution right now let's all
get vaccinated against flu will have
that vaccine in hand and we can do
something about that infection and give
us lettuce from what you know about a
possible vaccine for the corona virus
for the kovat 19 illness well Brian
everybody's working very hard on that I
hesitate to make predictions although
there is a hope that perhaps early in
2021 or at least sometime next year we
will have at least one vaccine available
to us but then when that happens the
hard work just begins it's likely to
require two doses which means giving
many many people two doses of a vaccine
and creating that sort of a delivery
system and actually persuading people to
take the vaccine will still take a great
deal of work and you mentioned people
who have been hesitant to take even the
flu vaccine this could be much more
difficult right and do you think when it
comes it will be proven safely be tested
well enough given the accelerated pace
we're seeing right now we're working
very fast and we're doing things
simultaneously that we used to do in
sequence but we're not cutting corners
we will only have vaccines available for
the general public that are shown to be
effective and safe how effective they
are remains to be seen we need that
information so we can complete
communicate that with complete clarity
and honesty it is amazing to see more
dozens and dozens of possible vaccines
now going through the testing stages
there are several though that are in the
front of the pack right there yes there
are several at the front of the pack
although as you say there are around
it's been estimated a hundred scientific
groups around the world trying to create
vaccines there are four or five that are
already in more
advanced clinical trials and we await
the results of those trials as we go
forward it's very it's an exciting time
there are a number of different
possibilities and perhaps more than one
horse will come in and it's quite a
tribute I think to the medical and
scientific community that they're able
to do this so quickly with some
coordination it seems some cooperation
everybody is being quite open within
limits of course but nonetheless an
awful lot of scientific work had been
done before kovat hit the scene and I
know for a fact that the moment the
Chinese investigators announced the gene
Act the genetic structure the genome of
the virus our investigators at the
National Institutes of Health
within hours began developing and
working on a vaccine that's an amazing
story dr. William Schaffner thank you so
much for joining us tonight
my pleasure Brian coming up next this
week's winners and losers in the media
but first the difficulty of getting
justice for police officers who
misbehave and who killed will talk of to
lawyers and get a reality check
you're watching the long crime trial
Network
[Music]
well we've all seen those videos not
very many good but a lot of them bad and
ugly raising difficult questions about
police misconduct and the issue of
whether police who misbehave badly
misbehaved could ever be prosecuted so
many other did you seem to show the
police as if they feel they'll never be
held accountable we have updates to that
show of force against peaceful
protesters yesterday in Lafayette Park
across from the White House concede
police here now firing tear gas into the
crowd they are trying to push these
folks back everyone's been hit by it's
just
and so the question is can police who
misbehave can they be held accountable
in a court of law
joining me to talk about that in
addition to my colleague Rhonda Schwartz
are two other colleagues of mine from
law and crime Mike Carr bannocks
in New Jersey and Eklund Mercy in
Georgia thank you both for being here
let me start with you if I could Eklund
you've seen those videos but oftentimes
the police get away with it yeah yeah
oftentimes because of qualified immunity
and it essentially just gives officers
carte blanche to do what they want to do
there's that video in which you had two
officers to able by the officers push a
75 year old man and there was no reason
for it so if your lethal if you're if
your threshold for if your threshold for
an actual threat is a 75 year old man
and you can aim you find it in your mind
that it's okay to push him with all your
force and then when you make bond and
after you're finally arrested for you to
get a hero's welcome that's the type of
world that we live in today so they can
get away with anything at this point it
seems that I feel like white America
needs to look inward and figure out
where is their conscience they asked us
about peaceful protests and saying that
we should have peaceful protests but
never once I'm told nobody has ever told
us what will make you what will make you
feel that we're worthy
what will make us human to you we told
you that this is happening you see that
it's happening what else do you need
for us to tell you hey were worthy were
human you know you guys have to have
that conversation because you see that
officers
overstepping their bounds every single
day now
people are dying saying they can't
breathe and because their skin has been
weaponized and it's okay it's justified
so I feel that the question shouldn't be
with black people it should be with
white people like what what will it take
for you to find us worthy of life what
will it take for you to find us worthy
of the inalienable rights that we all
possess which is life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness what what what can
we do or what can you guys do within
yourselves to be okay with it
right all true microbats let me ask you
give us a reality check what actually
happens in the courtroom when officers
are held accountable they have the
videos and too often they seem to be
found not guilty or acquitted or
sometimes the charges are dropped
what's going on in the court well it's
it's always very difficult because as
eklund said there is a perception out
there that police officers because they
are police officers and the people that
are accusing them have been accused of a
crime it's a very difficult hurdle for
prosecutors to get over when they're
presenting the case to a jury I mean we
see videotapes that last maybe anywhere
from 1 to 15 minutes in many of these
cases and there's a reason why they take
months and months to try there's a very
long process that has to go on it's very
difficult for the prosecutors offices
because I think there for them to remove
themselves and say mostly deal daily
with the police officers within their
own jurisdiction so I think there needs
to be some thought on the review as to
how these cases are prosecuted and
perhaps some sort of special units that
are removed from the daily court actions
because police officers are appearing in
court on other cases they are considered
to be on the government and the side of
right and we have a in
thought--and jurors because that's
ultimately who makes the decision of the
jurors and it's very difficult for the
state when they're prosecuting to get
over the fact that they're police
officers in these people's perceptions
many of haven't had run-ins what I'm
saying is something about specific
police officers who do wrong I'm not
speaking about police officers in
general I'm speaking about those few
people who tarnish the reputation of the
people who are doing their job
accordingly but it makes it very
difficult for these prosecutions because
there's already priests conceived
notions before it gets the trial and
neckla mercy you mentioned qualified
immunity the Supreme Court's going to
hear arguments about that this week but
give us in just a minute or so because
we have to go on to our next one give us
a sense of what that means
what is qualified immunity well
qualified immunity kind of popped up
around the Civil Rights Act when the
Civil Rights Act passed so although you
mean we don't have slavery and although
we have you know the Civil Rights Act
hey we have a way to be able to protect
officers from police brutality claims
not only police brutality things from
civil claims from criminal claims that
when done during their course of work
it's virtually impossible to win a case
with qualified immunity they are
protected and another thing is that not
only do they have qualified immunity
it's they are free to do whatever we
have Denisovan had over 70 complaints in
his file and was was still at the day of
George Floyd's death was training two
officers so that goes to show you that
not only do they have qualified immunity
they're protecting these types of
officers
so although we yes not a lot of officers
are bad and things of that nature then
Chauvin was training two officers and he
had 70 70 complaints and was still
allowed to roam the streets and the 70
complaints are the ones that we know of
we even have case law that
that people have people have sued to try
to get a higher IQ there is a there's an
IQ limit to even beat an officer like
the whole system needs to be revamped
because there they're not there they're
specifically putting officers that can
portray this like this systemic racism
upon these upon these towns these cities
and these neighborhoods like Denisovan
should have never been an officer and
you can see that now you absolutely
right and this is why the calls for
reform may not even go far enough and
there's all this talk about defunding
the police well Eklund Mercy I want to
thank you very much and Mike organics
important insights and what's going on I
appreciate very much you being here
tonight coming up next the winners and
losers in the media this week see if you
agree with the editors of media you're
watching the long crime trial Network
and we wrap up our program tonight with
this week's winners and losers in the
media as compiled by media we're joined
by a dragon who's the editor in chief of
media ID part of the Dan Abrams media
empire which of course also includes our
law and crime Network and Hayden a
tumultuous week for the media this week
always yes Brian we've got a couple of
winners and losers I'm excited to get to
them
yes let's start with the Washington Post
you declared a winner yeah so we have
two reporters at the Washington Post
here you might not know their names
they're not prominent figures on the
masthead but they did a really
interesting story that we caught that
took a look at various contributions
charitable contributions that the
wealthy have made now one of the people
that they looked at as part of this
piece was Jeff Pisa now he is the
founder of Amazon a billionaire by you
know hundreds of times over and he
actually owns the Washington Post so
they took a look at his contribution to
the fight against coronavirus and saw
that he had donated a total of 125
million to the relief effort now when
you that sounds like an impressive
number but when you actually look at his
net worth which is you know close to 150
billion it actually doesn't add up that
up to that much and they're reporting
found that if you compared that number
to that of a median household of median
American household it actually comes
around about to $85 which doesn't sound
like a lot so you know this was a really
interesting report and the fact that
these two Washington Post reporters made
Jeff Bezos who is effectively their boss
the focus of it is a win for them it's a
win for the Washington Post and it you
know aside from his charitable giving
it's the win that Jeff Bezos has that
level of independent between himself and
the newspaper that young absolutely
first hand going against the boss or
against the owner or the big man is
always difficult for a reporter and hats
off to them and to Marty Baron for
running the story next to loser Barry
White's right so Barry Weiss is part of
the opinion pages of the New York Times
now we've heard a lot about the New York
Times opinion section this week I
remember you know last week on the show
we were speaking about it a lot and this
is all continued fallout from their
publication of an op-ed by Senator Tom
cotton which was headline send in the
troops and called for the military to
intervene in the protests across the
United States now a lot of New York
Times staffers objected to that piece
being run they objected to it on factual
grounds and they also thought that it
put their lives in danger given that
there was fears that there would be a
military crackdown on room not just
protestors but reporter now Barry Weiss
weighed in on this on Twitter she's
often had sort of controversial takes on
these sorts of subjects compared to the
rest of the New York Times staff um she
described the tensions at the New York
Times over this op-ed as a civil war
between what she's called the mostly
young wokes
at the paper and the mostly 40-plus
liberals who are disagreeing over
whether or not voices like Tom Cotton's
should be tolerated at the newspaper now
the the merits of Barry Weiss's argument
aside a lot of people at the paper
thought that was a complete
mischaracterization of the what they
described as the thoughtful debate that
was going on within the paper about the
publication of this op-ed she was called
lazy and intellectually dishonest by
people at her own paper and and not an
insignificant amount a lot of people
from the New York Times criticized Barry
Weiss over the way that she described
the civil war at the paper which he
basically cast as sort of a clash
between PC liberals who you know needed
a safe space from Tom cotton views and
old-school media types that perhaps were
more tolerant of his views um now you
know right we're not looking at the what
yeah before it perfect but let's jump
ahead here to another loser James
Barrett because it
ties right in yeah so James Bennett was
the you know editorial page editor at
the New York time so he oversees the
entire opinion section and he was
actually responsible for Tom Cotton's
off head being published now here's the
thing he didn't actually read Tom
Cotton's odd op-ed before it was
published now that came out in the
aftermath of the controversy over this
op-ed being published by the New York
Times you know James Bennett came clean
and said that he hadn't read it there
was a review of Tom Cotton's op-ed and
that review by the New York Times
claimed that there were several factual
errors in the op-ed and that it tone was
off and not in line with the paper and
they said that they should never have
published it they appended a big editors
notes top of the op-ed and after several
days of that controversy after James
Bennett admitting that he hadn't read
this very incendiary column before it
was published he resigned on Sunday
night now that is a huge story at the
newspaper and for media in general
because James Bennett was widely seen as
a potential successor to Dean bouquet
who the current current top editor at
the the New York time so it's a real
reordering of the masthead at the New
York Times and it's a it's a huge loss
and blow for James Bennett who has is
that a priest you know one of the most
senior editor positions at the time a
week ago and is now out of a job he
walked the plank essentially your next
winner
Mitt Romney tell us about that let's
first take a look at this video violence
and to make sure that people understand
the black lives matter MIT just wants to
make sure that Americans understand get
through their thick heads that black
lives matter as if Americans didn't know
that so there was Senator Romney
marching in the black lives matter being
taken apart by Tucker Carlson at Fox
right and we thought that that criticism
from Tucker Carlson was was harsh and a
little bit misguided you know I think it
it was fairly stunning to see Mitt
Romney not only March with these
protesters but also declare multiple
times in interviews with the Washington
Post on
during these protests that black lives
matter now Brian like I I can't even
imagine that we're at a point where
there is a Republican senator that is
uttering the words black lives matter
which is I feel like it's something that
would be unheard of just a couple years
ago you know this is Mitt Romney
basically stripping what should be a
non-controversial statement that black
lives matter but stripping it of its
sort of culture war baggage that it's
had for the past couple years and it was
really refreshing to see a Republican
senator do that I don't think that the
criticism from Tucker Carlson was in any
way warranted or accurate tucker carlson
has been criticizing these protests from
the start so it's no surprise to see him
go after mit romney particularly because
written mitt romney has been critical of
president donald trump who also
criticized mitt romney for marching in
these protests it you know it's good to
see the senator do that we'll heard was
the only other Republican that we really
saw March in these that he's a
congressman from Texas so we gave Mitt
Romney the media when not only for
marching but for also getting criticism
dr. Karl absolutely almost like a badge
of honor and finally we've got one
minute from for a loser Oh a n1 American
Network take a look at this video
it's the latest tensions of the Buffalo
Police Department's could be a result of
a false flag provocation by far left
group antiphon according to the
conservative tree house Saturday seventy
five-year-old protestor Martin Gucci no
saved by the Buffalo Police at last
week's protest is a well-known activist
bragging on social media about far-left
views alright we've got 30 seconds
they're spreading some conspiracy
theories that just don't hold up right
Oh a n yeah that's one American news
network a very Pro Trump conspiracy
theory minded network that was spreading
this wild theory about that protester
that theory was touted by Trump on
Twitter became a huge controversy for
the day it's a terrible network it was a
terrible segment bad that the president
promoted it I'll leave it at that are
all right Aiden McLaughlin editor in
chief of media thank you so much for
joining us and thanks to all of you for
watching us for this special report of
Brian Ross investigates and thanks to
our team at law and crime Network for
getting us on the air
and off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]